[Music]
this is maybe one of the more startling
articles we will do today things
something that you will hear you
probably will not even believe
okay but it happened hit us with it a
waffle house waitress allegedly pulled a
gun on a customer
what i mean it is waffle house what city
yeah it's pretty possible is it ihop
what was the what was the customer doing
atlanta georgia very doable
i think i'm on the waitress's side too
yeah already i don't even know yeah
that's a lot of the ass customers suck i
think more customers need to go and pull
them on yeah i agree dude i think i
think some servers should be able to
talk some [ __ ] back yeah i think some
customers should have to suck on the gun
too
yeah dude
to live to save their life
yo there are some pieces of shits out
there who are complete [ __ ] to
server work service workers because they
know that they can't do anything back to
them so people want to see the world
burn yeah you know sometimes you have to
serve those people
i took it because i was like i just want
tip so whatever [ __ ] it so candy
franklin said that an argument with a
waitress over food sizzled out of
control on wednesday morning it all
quote it all happened over cheese eggs
at first candy they did not bring them
to me oh then they brought me normal
eggs and i said i ordered eggs with
cheese on it i tipped her in everything
it was all a normal dispute over food i
never in a million years thought it
would come to gun violence oh [ __ ]
franklin said the gun of this one it
happened in downtown atlanta i was
looking down at my food making sure
it was right and that's when i saw
people running i looked up
she has a gun on me
oh [ __ ] i didn't think she would shoot
then she cocked it back oh [ __ ] so i was
like maybe she's about to do something
now it's time for me to turn to rambo
get out of here
so that is true the first random movie
he was a coward who fled yeah he ran
away yeah she said now it's time to
that's what it says
it's time for me to turn around we'll
get out of here so she must be a little
bit in her 40s maybe she remembers
rainbow fan could be yeah remembers
rambo rambo and she knows the first
rambo yeah before they ruined booby
traps in the [ __ ] forest exactly
um
so atlanta police are investigating the
incident um the customer who you guys
all judge and said they should have a
gun damn it i was so wrong you were
wrong see mind blown we do we misjudged
i don't know though because candy can
obviously be giving us the watered-down
version yeah what's the other side
yeah candy could be missing the part
where she was like what the [ __ ] i said
cheesy eggs [ __ ] well the other side
she could have left that out they
couldn't reach they couldn't reach the
other side because they pulled a gun at
candy
yeah but they weren't able to interview
her candy forgot the part where she says
i'm gonna go to my car and get my gun
and kill your ass right yeah
can you carry a gun like that candy
probably did it what's that what's the
gun laws oh they definitely can carry
guns you guys didn't hear about the baby
pulling a gun at walmart yeah i heard
about that a baby pulled a gun
baby oh everyone dave chapelle talked
about that okay okay sorry i was i was
like a a baby pulled a gun that sounds
[ __ ] different
try me yeah
i'm not shocked you're shocked a
representative from waffle house said
it's just another day
[Laughter]
no
they received the customer complaint and
they're launching why can't they open up
a waffle house here though yeah because
i would love it yeah we'll see some
crazy [ __ ] too but the eggo waffle kind
of stuff like oh come on we're gonna
make some fancy little brunch spot dude
i just want a regular diner yo we need
to have more diners we have a hell of
adorable what about this small where
it's small danny's ihops carol not
waffle house pancakes oh that's a chain
and waffles
is small
it's flat and something pops dude that's
what we want and in the chairs they got
the booth it's a snow
that's a good jojo tsukawa right there
um so
the the victim says that they're
no more waffle house for me at all
they're down in the waffle house after
this they're taking their business else
they are out there taking it to 2 a.m
yeah that's true going right back there
don't blame waffle house it was just the
waiter it was just the waitress dude who
had a gun on her in her apron what are
you gonna do when did you when did you
guys first
try waffle house do you remember yeah i
think i was 19.
when i went to uh north carolina for the
first time i've never been to alpha same
i had it at first with you guys when we
were in florida in florida right because
we were like waffle house so he's a
southern thing yeah yeah it's on to the
southern states what do you get when you
go there what's the move you gotta get
the waffles dude i know but besides that
like give me the full order i forgot
what they call this but with your hash
browns you could get grilled onions and
cheese put on your hashtag oh wow that
sounds good yeah you get would you go
there to get some grits you gonna get
cheese
eggs i would try the cheese eggs now
yeah
but i wouldn't complain about them yeah
definitely if they don't bring it out
i'm gonna be [ __ ] mad dude that
pretty bob melts too oh yeah melts
like patty melts yep [ __ ] love patty
melts
dude
but everyone
that lives there like wherever there's a
waffle house we're like oh take us to
waffle house and they'll be like what
and i'm like you don't understand what's
that synonymous to for us
denny's probably danny's bombing
everywhere cause no one gets hyped over
denny yeah you get hyped over daddies
obviously not
i kind of do though what's the last time
with the daddy's it's been a long time
but when i do go it's usually like a
[ __ ] memorable occasion okay i'm not
gonna lie
holiday danny's is pretty sick because
they have different [ __ ] what's that
they're like seasonal items and [ __ ]
yeah they have all like the fans just
because they throw in some cranberries
in there yeah yeah that's it dude throw
some cranberries in my pancakes i'm sold
i still prefer like just the mom and pop
diners
aren't just though no okay but i know
some good are we gonna say waffle house
is better than like francis roscoe's no
no not even rascals is better way
way better they don't have fried chicken
is that the is that the closest thing
it's the same kind of waffles though
i see what you mean yeah yeah we got the
close squares yeah you can't go to
roswell's like three in the morning
though that's the problem yeah yeah
that's true because they're not 24 7.
they're not waffle houses that's why
this [ __ ] exists well it has big mama
there's always a big mama there
she literally got a name that's his big
mama really yeah there's always a big
mama i don't know something i never see
that one
it's like it must be like a branding
thing yeah yeah yeah
look at all the liberties on the wall
true true does waffle house have
celebrity picks definitely not
yeah they don't have an obama special at
the waffle house
it has bill clinton on it and obama
that's why they look at it so they're
like wow
because it's like a denny's
my favorite norm mcdonald joke was that
he's like he's on 2020 with barbara
walters or like on the view and he's
like bill clinton murdered a guy right
and barbara's like you can't say that on
my show and he's like oh sorry
involuntary man
really yeah yeah yeah did you guys hear
about the fc [ __ ] down on it
there's some new epstein [ __ ] and then
there's new reports coming out how he
was he has uh dirt on trump and clinton
that he was going to release
[Music]
i was going to release it well why don't
people just release it then please
release it somebody do it release it
dude
they never do
what do you think bart how do you feel
about all this stuff
i hate these half secrets
just saying what the [ __ ] i just wanna
know what it is already i was i was
listening to the journalist who was
talking about why
in journalism or whatever like in media
they avoid this
like the epstein [ __ ]
is because
if you think about how connected epstein
was
everybody will get [ __ ] uh yeah so
like republicans and democrats will get
[ __ ] yeah so during that time they're
like none of us wants to deal with it
and the media because all the top dudes
like
all the cnns and the fox and all of them
all of them were connected so they're
just like
we don't wanna republicans and democrats
are at war with each other dude
they hate each other
i don't get it
there's going to be some crazy
revolution and just absolutely benefit
anyone because
it's basically shooting yourself in the
foot except for the justice for
everybody that's all not a big deal
though let's not focus on the victims
about the story my friend it's kind of
like
if all the ceos went to the same brothel
together
and they got caught
that would just be
right for them yeah it's so much
[ __ ] for everyone at the same time
so they're just trying to
sleep
because it's like why would they and
probably with all that stuff being
released nothing's going to happen to
them anyway right i don't think so they
won't get in trouble except for justice
slightly for the victims who [ __ ] up
and that when epstein died the night he
died i don't even know i heard they got
homes all of a sudden they bought some
new homes no figure
i live in a group
i thought they were gonna um this year
they were gonna deal with what's her
name glenn's glamour oh yeah what's up
with her she's chilling talks about it
probably bought a new home yeah dude
she's probably living it up right now
[Music]
um
[Music]